I think there's two main figures that
one will talk about the athletic read or
the Salafi Creed or that even a humbly
write method that come to mind
immediately which one of them was in
Tamia about 728 eh you know about the
movement yeah I was gonna say also now
the second one is it now I'm Amanda how
many loud will have died 1792 M milady
type which is Gregorian calendar yeah so
the in terms of their their approaches
for my study this is what I've come to
understand with even taymiyah even team
it didn't have these these views I want
to be clear about that and and I'll give
you some evidences for that it meant a
Mia had had an someone could Buckley and
his time okay I'm Buckley used to
believe in mr. Hoffa you know according
to you say yourself like that which even
taymiyah and other places may have
considered as as an awesome aslam as if
might consider that key or
something like that right but he wrote a
book with a lot while a Berkeley and in
this book he never made take fear of
Buckley and in fact not only did he
never make takfeer of Beck V but he
never he went back he was in trouble he
hit him in his house even though Buckley
metric field wouldn't say Mia by the way
yes so even Tamiya was though he is
sometimes invoked in these discussions
it's important to clarify to the viewers
because a lot of them would be thinking
yes it a Mia snow I actually made that
key his appearance and and many of his
senses are distinctly and starkly
different to what happened now it's a
little bit different because from from
my studies the question is did he make
did he have other agenda or not this is
the question about him particularly a
guy me with the example I believe now
the other Bridgend or not and there's
two opinions on that some scholars will
say because he said in one in one part
of his dual Sania
because you know these little books are
we talking about sort of third quadrant
and cash for sure hands and not Islam
yeah which is what these whic which is
what people read and then the thing the
hell us they've expired they have
exhausted knowledge he of course
the seriously thought people read these
books I think they have exhausted
knowledge
yeah blah anyway when you read daughter
Sania which is like the the main fat
hour of known him now what about those
who came after yes this does there are
some things of him where he says you
know in in could Nell a new careful man
yeah was a sanam you know if we are not
going to disobey make takfeer or
excommunication of those who do a habit
of a son literally worship a statue
yes then how about those individuals so
there are some things which we can take
from his words which maybe he doesn't
alter but John but other parts where he
seems like he's not saying that yes so
I'm not gonna say I know the answers to
that and say okay he's this will he's
dead but there are these two opinions of
him those who came after him had
different mindset completely why not
just deal with what actually took place
historically yes so that's those who
came usually after in his grandchildren
so what actually did take place was that
there was an armed rebellion against
mannequin ever and I love the reason
yeah treason and a lot of the
theological justification the legal
justification was that the the were not
just devious they were they they had
apostate right yes that's that's clearly
that's any yeah I mean there's no and
anyone trusted deny this I can we can
find them that they this references in
abundance in a button yeah an abundancy
I just as long as we make them clear
that this is not we're not talking
necessarily about booty Mia because
that's just someone don't know ever and
even in that little head there's a
question mark around that so we're
talking about because it Doris any is
probably one of the best texts primary
technical rules of this mindset
yeah and roots of this mindset goes back
to them periods yes yes for sure so
therefore given that understanding and
given the evolution of this movement and
this thinking and the fact they still
exist in the form of bas pubs
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba them of that you know
they do in
yeah of course yeah but the point in it
the way it manifests in the Muslim world
does not literally mean death it could
do you that I has done a living while
using Libya so some time saying here
okay it's PDF presentations right
they made areas where this life and the
ground for Miley is like it's the same
justification well I just don't get it
because you know in Libya as you know if
he swerves I'll hack him
yeah who's the hack him well there's two
Hawkins at the moment is a dispute okay
so yes this is my question and by the
way I accept the premise that we
shouldn't do hogeol hack and Muslim I
agree with that prayer this is the
humble review this is why follow we
shouldn't do Horizonte him and Muslim
and and also we agree with the premise
that we don't want to start civil wars
in different countries and we don't we
don't want another Syria we don't want
another Syria but I'm not saying having
said that we can't say that you know
what happened to the Syrian people was
in vain these were heard that of course
and of course there were deviant groups
and there were criminal groups like Isis
that came out and that's horrible and we
don't and those groups not just Isis but
those who are related to their kind of
thought process you have criminals by
the same time this started off as a
person who was not a Muslim a Bashar al
Assad was not a Muslim right he's his al
away and from our perspective that's
nice lamb and he was killing his people
you know these people came out and so
and whole July he is is coming out
against him it's not the same as coming
out against someone who at least have
marvelous lemons is I and let's keep in
mind as well that the aamna issue did
not raise arms first
it becomes the issue of defending
themselves for survival to respect the
women for the lamb in the prime salute
the regime turned the guns on to the
amount protester that's when they had to
resort only had defections from from
that all